we are now ready to start we have to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
match today here and by conference and I
will read statement
the committee expressed its deep concern
about the ongoing outbreak which despite
some positive epidemiological trends
especially in the epicenters of to tango
and cara in the Democratic Republic of
Congo shows that the extension of the
reintroduction of disease in other areas
like Malakal presents once again
challenges around community acceptance
and security in addition that the
response continues to be hampered by a
lack of adequate funding and strained
human resources the cluster of cases in
Uganda that was detected earlier this
week is not unexpected
the rapid response and initial
containment of that cluster is a
testament to the importance of
preparedness in the countries that
neighbours the Democratic Republic of
Congo
and the committee commenced the
communication and collaboration between
dr congo and uganda at the same time the
expectations of cases in to uganda is a
reminder that as long as this outbreak
continues in dr congo
there will be a risk of spread to
neighboring countries the risk of spread
to countries outside the region remains
low
the committee wishes to commend the
heroic work of all responders who
continue to work under extremely
challenging and stressful conditions the
committee extensively debated the impact
of a declaration of a public health
emergency of international concern on
the response and the possible unintended
consequences of such a declaration and
how such consequences might be managed
different differing views were expressed
as the committee acknowledged that
recent cases in Uganda constitute
international spread of disease so our
conclusion and advice are as follows it
was the view of the committee that the
outbreak is a health emergency in the
Democratic Republic of Congo
under medium but it does not meet all
the three criteria for a public health
emergency of international concern under
the ihr under international health
regulations while the outbreak is an
extraordinary event and there's risk of
international spread we believe that the
ongoing response would not be enhanced
by formal temporary recommendations from
whu-oh under international health
regulations
the committee provided a range of advice
to the whu-oh to the member states and
it strongly urges countries and partners
to heed this advice at risk countries
should improve their preparedness for
detecting and managing exported cases as
Uganda has done this week cross border
screening in the Democratic Republic of
Congo should continue and its quality
improved and sustained
whu-oh should closely monitor and
publish progress on preparedness in the
neighboring countries of the DRC and
double Ashok should continue to map
population movements and sociological
patterns that can predict risk of
disease spread all the priority
countries should put in place approvals
for investigational medicines and
vaccines as an immediate priority for
preparedness and optimal vaccine
strategies that have maximum impact
impact on curtailing the outbreak as
recommended by the whe Rose own
strategic advisory group of experts
should be implemented rapidly and now
our most perhaps our most important
point the committee is deeply
disappointed that whu-oh and the
affected countries have not received the
funding and resources needed for this
outbreak
the international community must step up
funding and support for the
strengthening of preparedness and
response in the Democratic Republic of
Congo and the neighboring countries step
up funding the WTO and other partners
and the Democratic Republic of Congo
should continue to strengthen community
awareness engagement and participation
there has been a great deal of progress
in community engagement activities
however in border communities where
mobility is especially likely community
engagement needs to be more sharply
targeted to identify the populations
most at risk and the implementation by
by the United Nations and partners of
more coordinated measures to reduce
security threats mitigate security risks
and create an enabling environment for
Public Health operations is welcomed and
encouraged by the committee as an
essential platform for accelerating
disease control efforts the committee
strongly emphasizes its previous advice
against the application of any
international traveling flight
restrictions and we do not consider
entry screening at airports or other
ports of entry to be necessary and we
advise the WHL director-general to
continue to monitor the situation
closely and reconvened our committee as
needed and
for our meeting we we heard from
representatives of the governments of
the Democratic Republic of Congo and the
government of Uganda we heard from the
from the and we had to thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before questions just remind those
online to dial zero one on the key part
to be put in in the queue so we will
start with journalists here in the room
please and should use yourself and also
if you can just switch on the mic smell
microphone that is in front of you if
you want to ask a question
yes cat so we could so maybe I think so
any other questions from the room here
Jamie please come into microphone please
hi I'm Jamie from Associated Press so um
dr. habits and you mentioned that the
funding is strained you know why would
you not use a fake a call it an
international health emergency to be
able to help boost the funding it would
be a good way of boosting the funding
and my second question has to do with
the countries involved on Congo and
Uganda you mentioned that you had spoken
to officials in those countries what
kind of concerns did they express about
and announcing this as a as an health
emergency of international concern or
not thank you thank you we consider that
declaring a fake should follow the
criteria of the International Health
Regulations
and to declare it in an effort to try to
raise fund France would be a misuse of
the instrument there is an ongoing
severe outbreak an emergency in the
Democratic Republic of Congo where
children and adults and responders
health care personnel are dying from
this disease and that emergency in
itself is a reason for donors to fund to
response so that whe oh and the
ministers of health and all other
partners could put a stop to this
terrible outbreak
I don't think it's it is right for me to
go into details about the discussion
that a committee had with governmental
officials they briefed us on the
situation and on their concerns and on
several issues thank you
take your nutshell doctor
we'll take one more question from the
room that we will go to journalists who
are online and who should zero on
establish the content you can in 10 of
these are classified as high risk so the
Vandal authorities have cast a wide net
and are really having a very broad
definition of could represent risky
contact
the reason the vaccine is in country
their teams were listing those contacts
over the last 24 hours plus also the
context of those contacts so the process
today has been to establish that
exhaustive list of contacts and context
of contacts and it was felt better to
begin tomorrow with the fuller
comprehensive list of individuals three
vaccinators rather than doing it in a
piecemeal fashion that's the reason
there is no obstacle to actually getting
the work done it's making sure the the
the process is as comprehensive as
possible so let's go to journalists
online so I will call first and Helen
groundswell from stats you know the
committee consists of members of
different background the different
expertise and in the group many views
where we're represented and expressed
and we had a long and substantial
discussion after hour after presentation
of all the facts in the end we we do not
take votes we draft statement and we
agreed collectively on on the statement
that I I read out earlier
thank you very much for this as I said
we we don't do votes we we discuss
Center and we agreed collectively on on
the statement at the end that's how it's
done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
was that for me okay I wouldn't say that
but I would say that the lack of funding
makes the response in the Democratic
Republic of Congo and the preparedness
work in the neighboring countries makes
it more difficult and it may delay the
actual stamping out of this outbreak the
committee heard from WH o that I had to
scale back some of their preparedness
work in neighboring countries because of
lack of funds so so that's why the the
committee thinks that the first step now
for every country around the world with
worried about Ebola outbreak in
Democratic Republic of Congo the first
step for them is to at least make sure
that the funding is in place to respond
and prepare to the outbreak thank you
very much next question comes from
Katrina
[Music]
[Music]
to recognize that the Ugandan
authorities have really proven the value
thus far of investments and preparedness
an ounce of preparedness is daily worth
more than a ton of response very modest
amounts of funding have been used to
support Uganda and achieving a very high
level of preparedness both in terms of
the the border the screening the
establishment of Ebola treatment units
enhanced community based surveillance
community mobilization the establishment
of laboratories and many other measures
like safe and dignified burial teams in
April the Ugandan authorities with
partners ran a full-scale exercise in
this very area to test all of these
procedures and again the fact that these
procedures worked that the communication
was in place the lab samples got to
where they needed to go the patients
were property isolated and those that
unfortunately died were already buried
again shows that it is possible for all
countries to achieve adequate and very
significant levels of preparedness
however
the last three to four months very
little funding has been available in the
preparedness space the budget for
preparedness in the four most at-risk
countries was six was over sixty million
dollars ninety seventy million dollars
but there's still a gap in that funding
of twenty seven million dollars as we
speak
and that's through to the end of June
currently the teams in the field are
doing a carrying out an option
operational review in collaboration with
the Ministry of Health the World Bank
and the response coordinator and a new
strategic response plan further further
response will is currently being
clustered there will be a significant
task within that new response plan that
is in addition to the existing gap in
the current response for about 38 Rome
partners so there is a significant gap
in funding for the response there is a
significant gap in funding for
preparedness both of these will need to
be met not just for wo but for the
countries for the partners but again and
again we must recognize the role their
surf funding from Marco Cox team and
Archer it was the first time that
advanced funding was giving for
preparedness from cell phones in the for
most at-risk countries and that
$10,000,000 did a tremendous amount of
good and helping those countries get
ready and again I think the return on
that investment thus far is obvious so
it is belief of the secretaries that we
need to continue to fund preparedness
and do preparedness support countries in
doing it it is a good investment in
health security for those countries and
health security for the world with
regard to preparedness in countries more
distant theirs
there is never any Harman countries
preparing in fact Legere has been a
heightened level of preparers
preparedness for the last year to two
years because of the threat of Lassa
fever and ongoing endemic and epidemic
on endemic Lassa fever plus monkey pox
so the capacities room in nigeria to
scale up their own internal operations
is actually become quite impressive and
we were very pleased to see countries
testing exercising and developing higher
capacities to be able to detect and
respond to any infectious disease threat
we do advise against actions we advise
against restrictions and we encourage
countries to invest in public and we
were very very pleased with the news the
company will reengage its research
production plant at West Point in the US
which will effectively double the
capacity of the company to produce
vaccine or well coming here this is
welcome use at the moment their quarter
of a million doses ready to ship and we
will have a further 100,000 doses before
the end of the year as you know listen
to and the intervention by dr. at
Roseland there's currently sage
recommendations for the adjusted dose
usage which have been approved for half
the current dose of vaccine in Congo
they've been approved and that has been
implemented so effectively we've doubled
the availability of doses in the field
further deliberations will occur at the
level of the sage working group or
novella virus disease and the sage
committee itself to look us any
necessary further adjustment of those
doses going forward we are also working
very hard with the consortium led by the
Institute NASA now the research biology
in Kinshasa and a consortium of agencies
like the London School of Hygiene the UK
Rapid Response Teams for the potential
introduction of a vaccine produced by
J&J that's protocol is currently under
approval at the National regulatory and
ethical authorities and we would hope to
have that vaccine in country which will
also offer another alternative for
boosting vaccination in the field we're
very pleased at the moment with the
current announcement by a primer we're
cognizant and conscious of the fact that
vaccine supply this is a very precious
commodity a very precious resource we
have to use it extremely wisely
and we will we will continue to do so we
do believe that with current projections
and with the plans adjustment of dose we
should have an affecting to deal with
the scenarios that we face but Ebola is
a ray unforgiving disease we must
constantly keep the epidemiology under
review and we will certainly revert to
the international community and to the
manufacturers should we believe that the
increased production that has been put
on the table yes I could
you may share information about the
disease spread even if the affected
countries don't want wso to do it and
the second is that whu-oh may give
temporary recommendations to the member
states that the member states have to
follow now both of those consequences
are really not needed because the
affected country and Uganda are
extremely transparent and temporary
recommendations are not needed because
all the countries involved and the rest
of the world is really already following
the advice that
whu-oh is giving so for that reason that
there is is no need for declaring
national concern on the other hand there
may be some risks of declaring such such
or making such a declaration and this is
connected to how such a declaration is
perceived namely as a global emergency
but this is not a global emergency it's
an emergency the Democratic Republic of
Congo a severe emergency and it may
affect neighboring countries but
bye-bye if if someone thinks that it it
would be a global emergency we risk to
see as we have seen with previous public
health emergency of international
concern we risk to see restrictions on
travel and trade we risk to see Airlines
stopping their flights to the area and
we've also risked border closures or
restrictive measures at border that
could severely harm the economy in the
Democratic Republic of Congo so it was
the view of the committee that there is
we had nothing to gain by declaring a
fake but there is potentially a lot to
lose
thank you final question for the evening
and Jason from NPR Jason can you hear us
[Music]
[Music]
yes you've seen the recommendations of
the committee itself that they do
specifically recommend those priority
countries should put in place the
necessary approvals for investigational
medicines and vaccines as an immediate
priority of preparedness as we speak the
government authorities in Uganda are
approving in the process of approving
the miry protocol which is the protocol
medians for introducing the the
therapeutics the investigation used
therapeutics and those drugs are on
standby to be delivered obviously the
reason of moving sick child before was
to give that child the opportunity to
beat rusev in you know sophisticated as
their isolation facility with the
availability of therapeutics and an
ongoing randomized control trial which
is currently underway in Beni it will be
preferable that countries have in place
the newer protocol having placed the
drugs and those drugs are available and
available free to those countries for
their use but again you have to
distribute those drugs in a very
judicious way because we can't supply
huge amounts of drugs to every country
so you have to base that distribution of
drugs to countries based on meat but
that doesn't prevent countries approving
the protocol and getting ready to be
able to use those drugs so we will
ensure that any country that these these
drugs will get them
posthaste so that would be the the the
the current situation regarding that and
we will expect that countries will
continue to vaccinate health workers
will continue to do whatever is needed
in terms of preparedness but it's not
just the technologies for preparedness
the very simple measures of increasing
community since its sensitizing
communities to the their seriousness of
Ebola watching out for unusual symptoms
avoiding stigmatization of people who
may be having Ebola especially health
workers being vaccinators being alert
and knowing what to do if they see a
suspect case knowing who to call and
knowing that if they call someone
something will happen
someone will come to check someone will
come to investigate so there are much
more simple probably God measures that
we need to take but certainly it is a
great advance at the moment to be able
to access these novel therapeutics to be
able to access effective vaccine and
that is a real step forward in terms of
global health security we will close
this press conference I think all
journalists here in the room well
journalists online everyone who is
watching us on our Twitter account and
special thanks to dr. sound of Tirana
and dr. Tetris who who spoke to all of
you today the audio file will be
available shortly and transcript later
in the evening have a wonderful day
evening thank you very much
[Applause]
oh it's a much very appreciated problem
you're all my friends huh
okay I'm not evening YouTube